[Music]
hi guys i'm lauren zima we are about to
sit down with this is us star Mandy
Moore and talk about all of her favorite
friendsgiving traditions
Mandy's partnering with American Express
and if you want tips on holiday decor
recipes and more you can head to
American Express comm slash
friendsgiving let's find out what Mandy
has to say what are some of your
favorite holidays you just got really
excited because I love the holidays I
love this time of year like Halloween on
I just get giddy I booked like norms and
had not had the traditional Thanksgiving
for the past couple of years so I'm
going to be co-hosting friendsgiving
this year with my future mother-in-law
and I've partnered up with American
Express and their blue cash everyday
card which I use every day and it gives
you cash back on things that you
purchase all the time like groceries
which are really helpful during the
holidays especially if you're gonna be
hosting so it felt like a really organic
fit to come together and to celebrate
all things friendsgiving
so you and Taylor are really fusing the
families at this point we're fusing the
families my immediate family who are all
gonna be celebrating this year which is
the first time in a while but then a ton
of friends it has like the potluck vibe
you get a drink and pie then you're good
to go like the highlight of the day
right